Hello, everyone. This is Anne. I am a genetic and nutrition counselor here with Connors Clinic.
And today I'm going to take you through a little presentation I made just going over DNA,
methylation, epigenetics, and the Connors Clinic genetic review. So what does all of this mean?
So what we're going to talk about is understanding your DNA, just kind of going back to the basics and
getting that foundation down of what we're talking about, what we're talking about DNA. We're going to go
over methylation, what it is, what is epigenetics. And then how do we apply these two
our genetic review here? And then there's two little images here. The first one is just an image of
what the packaging looks like for our Connors Clinic sample collection kit for getting your DNA.
And then we have the 23 and me collection kit here. Many people have already done their 23
and me, and they have that data and information. We can use that, upload that into our software,
and get the results and go over a genetic review with you from your 23 and me information. Otherwise,
we do have our own kit here as well. So DNA 101, what are we talking about here? So we're talking
about what we inherit from our parents. So DNA, that's what we again inherit from our parents. It's
a set of 23 chromosomes from mom and a set of 23 chromosomes from dad. So each of these 46
chromosomes pair up and create our individual DNA. And DNA is what makes each and every one of us unique.
This is how we were born. It's our genetic blueprint. Our DNA provides every ounce of instructions,
our cells need to become complete living beings. Every cell in our body contains all of this DNA.
However, not all of it is needed for each cell to function. Each cell only uses or expresses certain
genes that pertain to its particular cell type and its needs. So here's just a little visual here of
DNA. So the purple is indicating a set of the chromosomes from mom and then the blue is from dad. And
that's how they pair up into our DNA. How do ourselves know which genes to express in order to
perform their function? Good question, right? So here we're talking about methylation and our DNA.
So within each cell, our DNA is tagged with tiny chemicals called methyl groups that they attach
to a part of a gene sequence and they modify the expression of that particular gene. These chemical
tags cause some genes to be turned off in order to allow for expression of only the DNA that is required
for that cell to function. So for example, a muscle cell will have genes turned on that are required
for muscle cell function and genes turned off that are not required for that function.
Methylation allows for this which is called cell differentiation. And this is important because
differentiation is what allows liver cells to become liver tissue, then function as the liver organ
and work as part of the complete organ system within the human body. Methylation codes for this
organization and function instead of chaos. So if you can imagine if all of our cells are trying to
express all of our DNA information at the same time, it would just be complete in total chaos and
nothing would work properly. We need to have organization in order for things to function within our body.
During embryonic development, development, methylation signals come from within the cell itself and
from neighboring cells to form the human body. That's how our cells receive the instructions to
start forming the human body. But then as we age and develop, environmental signals become more
important and these signals will govern how we methylate, therefore govern how our body actually
ends up functioning. Environmental influences on methylation play a significant role in cancer
prevention. We want healthy methylation. So our tumor suppressor genes are not turned off. We need
healthy methylation to prevent chronic disease. It reduces inflammation and inflammation we know
is the root cause of a lot of different diseases. Healthy methylation is involved in detoxing chemicals
and toxins. So it's involved in our detox pathways. It's involved in neurotransmitter health, hormone
balance, immune cell function, energy production and so much more. So you can understand how important
methylation is. So what are these environmental signals that control how we methylate and
therefore control gene expression? So this is epigenetics. Epigenetics involves genetic control
by factors other than an individual's DNA methylation sequence. It's our environment.
Epigenetics is everywhere. It's what you eat. It's where you live. It's who you interact with.
It's the quality of your sleep whether or not you exercise and even just aging. All of these
signals eventually cause chemical modifications or DNA methylation takes that will turn genes on
or off over time. Genetic research has shown that our environment can change our genetic structure
far beyond what we inherited from our parents. So this is really important and I'll read it again.
Epigenetic research has shown that our environment can change our genetic structure far beyond what
we inherited from our parents. So we have more power. We have more control than just the blueprint we
were born with. We can control things. Our lifestyle habits, environmental conditions and toxic
exposures can change our genes to the point where those changes are passed on to our offspring.
So here's kind of an example of how a epigenetic or environmental factor can actually change
our DNA and change who we become or change how our genes are expressed. So an example is a queen B.
Queen B and worker bees are genetically identical, 100% genetically identical. The only difference is
that the queen bees are forced fed royal jelly from the larva stage and the worker bees are fed nectar,
pollen and water. So it's the royal jelly, the nutrition contents that are within that royal jelly
that switch on genes, which results in the development of ovaries and a large abdomen for egg laying
plus a queenly attitude that makes the worker bees do anything the queen B wants. Meanwhile,
the diet of the worker bee encodes first sterility. So if you just think about that and think about
just that simple change, a dietary change that completely changes the expression of the queen B
to be that of a queen. And here's just kind of a visual of epigenetic influences and to our cell.
So here's a cell here. So we have exercise, which increases your BDNF, which is brain-derived
neurotrophic factors. So exercise is sending signals to your cells here, nutritional factors. So what
we're eating is sending signals to our cells, the environment. So it's the air that we're breathing,
the water that we're drinking, the ground soil that we're getting foods from, whether or not we
smoke these are all sending environmental signals to our cells, which changes how our cells are
responding. Emotional health plays a role. So religion, meditation, spirituality. So our mental health
is really playing a role in sending signals to our cells. So all of these signals change again how
the cell is going to be expressed and how it changes the methylation patterns of our DNA,
which again is changing expression of our genes. And if we're sending the right signals,
we have anti-inflammatory, antioxidant, and anti-mutation signals going on here, which is all what we want.
So how does all of this apply to my genetic review? So the genetic review, methylation is involved in
almost every bodily biochemical reaction and occurs billions of times every second in our cells.
That's why figuring out where there are challenges in this cycle and how to help it perform better
will significantly significantly improve our health. Genetic variations, or sometimes variations,
it can be called a mutation, or a defect, or a snip. They play a very important role in the
methylation process. The presence of a snip is often a major factor in identifying the underlying
cause of imbalanced methylation. A snip may be present in one or both of the genes. When it's
present on one of the genes, it's called a heterozygous polymorphism. And when it is on both of the genes,
it is called a homozygous polymorphism. Our comprehensive genetic testing helps you identify your
snips so we can create an individualized plan to support any areas of concern. It gives you the
details of black and white and how your body is wired to function. Therefore, you can make dietary
lifestyle and supplemental tweaks to rewire or change methylation patterns in the areas you'd
like to overwrite. You can optimize your genetic potential to prevent an even reverse disease.
When we provide our body with the right environment and epigenetic factors, the methylation system
can work properly and we are more likely to be free from all of these things here. Obesity, cancer,
heart disease, infertility, bipolar, manic depression, MS and autoimmune disorders, ADD, ADHD, Alzheimer's,
anxiety, depression, all of these symptoms can be alleviated with healthy methylation.
And this here is just a little peek at some of the things that we look at when we are going
through your genetic review. So this is functional genomic analysis. We have what's called the pyramid
here where we look at all of these things. We look at diet, we look at gut health, nutrient utilization,
antioxidant production, antioxidant utilization, liver detox pathways, folate creation pathway,
methionine cycle, neurotransmitters, potential for iron dysregulation, potential for oxidative stress,
we look at vitamin D receptors, genes related to EMF sensitivity, and cardiovascular health. We look
at all of these potential stressors for your body that can disrupt methylation and provide a plan
to balance these stressors so your body functions to its potential. It's really exciting.
We kind of do this in phases. So as you can see here when we look at this pyramid,
these blocks down at the bottom, they're the foundational components to health and they really support
all of the things that fall on top of it. So we kind of start with the foundation and we look at
these things and we address those first. And then as we go on and follow up care, we can tweak
things. And eventually sometimes when we're just addressing the foundation of this pyramid, all
of the other things fall into place. Sometimes we do need to kind of support some of the things
at the top of the pyramid, but again, we look at everything as a whole and we start kind of with
these foundational pieces. And here's an example of the things that you would see in your report
on this right side here. We're looking at a few different families of genes. And then we have a
column that's indicating either a blank in a box, a one or a two. So those are showing the
snips or the polymorphisms that you might have, too, is for the homozygous polymorphism.
And a one would be for the heterozygous polymorphism.
And here is just kind of a it's called a pathway planner. So it's looking at some of the genes
that we go over. And you can see here how interconnected all of these genes are.
We have the MTHFR gene kind of right smack dab in the middle. MTHFR is really popular and a lot
of people will get an MTHFR gene test, but the test is only looking at that specific gene.
But when we're looking at even just this pathway planner, which is just a snippet of the genes
that we look at, we can see how interconnected everything is. So we never want to look at just
the MTHFR gene because it's related to all of these other pathways that surround it. So we like
to take a big and broad look at the genes, look at as many genes as possible. We look at symptoms,
we look at family history, we look at your goals to kind of create this comprehensive wellness plan
for you and your loved ones. We can also bring up cancer specific genes to determine if intervention is
necessary to support tumor suppressor genes in particular. So we like to take this whole body
approach and look at as many genes as possible to formulate your plan.
And it is possible you can take control of your health and feel good and live life to the fullest.
If you're interested in learning more about our genetic review process or genetic plan,
you can check out our website at connersclinic.com. There is a begin here button at the upper right hand
corner so you can look at that page at the very bottom or towards the bottom of that page. There's a
button that says genetic review only. You can click on that and get information on our genetic review plan.
And hopefully this helps. Thank you. Bye-bye.